this is a production of Cornell
University
um this is uh as Marvin indicated this
week I just finished my um my
dissertation as the title indicated and
um the whole spectrum of things I did or
are this I um I have five different
chapters and today
um so that it covers the past the
present and future
um but today we're going to be focusing
on these two chapters I'm not going to
be going to into everything everything
but if you do want to know more I'll
give you but giving a brief overview of
other chapters and if anything piece
your interests please feel free to reach
out happy to talk to you more about that
I want to be talking about some specific
field experiments done with hazelnuts
and chestnuts today
um and this overview
um of all the nuts that are native to
the Northeast so the one of the reasons
why I was really drawn to nuts is that
they are
um plants that are have been in this
landscape for thousands and thousands of
years
um and then that way they offer a lot of
ecological
um adaptations that are well suited to
this region
um and most of the nuts are come from
oak trees many different species of oak
trees and which have been in this
landscape for about 12 000 years
according to pollen records
um also hickories have been
um in this region as far as 8 000 years
going in in Western New York Corner
pollen records
American chestnuts first found uh
latitudes of 42 degree North 6 000 years
before present
walnuts to wear two different species
there's a black walnut children's
Niagara and the white walnuts or
Butternut children's scenario those have
also been in this landscape for
thousands of years the black one and
having a very interesting
um sudden peak in its pollen
um Pond uh what would you call it Pond
signal as early as 500 years ago so lots
of um recent interest in that it's also
two species of hazelnuts that are native
to this region and of course the
American Beach so there's a huge
diversity of nuts that are available in
this area that have been here for
at thousands of years
um so to do to part of the research that
I um engaged in was really trying to
figure out what is the history of people
using nuts in this area going back
through all time or deep time as far as
we can go and in order to answer that
question I like the ethnographic records
um these include um yeah here's just one
quote from from Arthur Parker who was an
ethnologist and also Seneca himself
uh Seneca are one of the nations in the
hudnisone Confederacy
um and so this quote reads that nuts
were an important part of the Iroquois
diets Iroquois another word for Hoda
nashoni it's more Antiquated not really
used anymore but great quantities were
consumed during the net season and
quantity is restored for winter use
the next season to the Iroquois was one
of the happiest periods of the year so
one of the really interesting things
that we see
um a lot of quotes like this portraying
lots of really high energy and
enthusiasm for nuts and then also
however that's contrasted with what's
found in the archaeological record which
is a lot of the archaeological rights my
new quantities I'm not fragments would
suggest that the rich source of oils and
nutrition from harvesting nuts was not
important
um to the occupants so there's a really
conflicting different kinds of reports
coming from different kinds of evidences
and so the first chapter of my
dissertation is really trying to
untangle this discrepancy what's what's
going on
um and in order to I I've developed a
hypothesis and in order to kind of see
through this I found that historical
ecology was a really important source of
information and I looked at a variety of
different sources which really indicated
that uh peoples were managing Forest in
ways that what we see is that uh
increase the abundance of nut trees in
the landscape it's called being hyper
dominant much more than they should be
and these are just a couple of figures
from these kinds of papers but here we
have in Western New York evidence of of
intentional Oak savannas where there
should not be these are areas where we
have Oaks separated
um from each other by some distance
growing in grass and then this is also a
map oops a map of fire mediated
Landscapes this is also in the very same
so here's like that little dip in Lake
Ontario Shoreline same thing right here
and then this is Keuka Lake and this is
a map of
um canopy disturbance and how that links
up with all these dots are locations of
different wooden shiny settlements and
agricultural sites
um and so this is just a really brief
overview of different kinds of evidences
I've considered and piecing to the story
this is not the main part of this topic
um the main the main you know the
um
the moral of the stories here that the
the forests were being heavily managed
and as a result nut trees were being
increased and this is really not that
surprising if you consider the kinds of
evidence is very similar kinds of
evidence is happening all across really
the world so there's other papers coming
out about this that happen in the east
in the Pacific Northwest there's a lot
of recent research showing indigenous
management is still uh The Echoes of
that are still measurable in Forest
communities today and this has also been
seen in the Amazon Amazon parts of it
are Giant Food forests and also in parts
of Asia
um so historical ecology has been a
really important
um and exciting field for me to look
into and if you want to learn more about
what uh you know this was about please
reach out
um another part of my research was doing
community-based work with contemporary
hoteli people I worked out Discovery or
Tuscarora nation which is in Western New
York about um a little bit north of
of um Niagara Falls
and so one of the primary questions I
was trying to ask there is what does
uh sustainable agriculture research and
education look like with contemporary
peoples in a way that addresses not only
this historical ecology but also works
um with you know with a Reconciliation
in mind and trying to
um really do justice to towards
relationship building
um and so this was you know when you
enter the nation uh there's a you know
different language
um literally in a different country even
though it's it's New York State
um and there are learning about research
protocols that are based off of treaties
that have been signed like as um this is
the two-row Wampum this is considered a
very important treaty that was
originally assigned between the Dutch
and the hodinosoni
um and this was uh this relationship was
transferred to the English that was the
whole point of the Canandaigua treaty uh
commemorating the Canandaigua tree
that's coming up November 11th
um but what this represents is that
these two um purple bars are symbolizing
um potentoshone canoes and white
European ships Going Down the River of
Life
um in peace and prosperity side by side
not interfering with one another and so
if you are interested
um in working with indigenous peoples
it's important to know that as a result
we are also treating people we have uh
roles and responsibility
um if we want to be building
relationships with um with people doing
environmental cooperation
um and and this was all based on um an
overview of This community-based
research was was based on uh indigenous
research methods coming out of the
Mohawk akasazane a reservation or a
community Mohawk is another Nation
within the nashoni Confederacy and so I
followed and looking for protocols and
how to actually engage in this kind of
work I looked towards existing
indigenous methodologies for cooperation
um which kind of followed this
three-part
um this three-part flow
of building peace developing Equity or
through a good mind and then developing
ways of creating empowerment ultimately
with the goal of sharing resources and
and Justice is the ultimate goal of this
kind of work this manifested into a
three-part Workshop series
um which uh I'll show you some pictures
but we did some tree walks and trade
identification and learning about
different stories of people's
relationships with nut trees on the
reservation we had nut processing
workshops where we actually took nuts
that I and other people harvested and we
made Foods out of them using both
contemporary and traditional methods and
recipes and then we also planted a lot
of trees on I'll give away a lot of
seedlings
um to folks out on the res but also
planted there on this on the there's a
school on the nation lands that we
planted a lot of plants on
so here's some pictures of the first
part of our event doing some tours
um there was a there's a business out
there that made some custom shirts for
us which was really funny black walnut
tie-dyed them and uh this
I don't know
um
decline
okay
we made some some cookies and this is a
homemade Nutcracker that one of the
nation members just like welded himself
um because that's what he was interested
in and he was a traditional corn pounder
that we're using for busting up um
Hickory nuts
and then we also did lots of plantings
where we allow these plants were either
grown by myself or collected donation
from local nurseries these were mostly
native nut and fruit trees but also we
had medicinal plants
um yeah and here's some uh planting
planting on the school grounds
and then uh so that was chapters one and
five I just showed you and now this is
chapter two or three I forget exactly
the exact order
um I did in a kind of a different
direction I worked with contemporary
peoples I conducted a um based on an
observation that I was making in my
field that a lot of you know other kinds
of farmers not necessarily indigenous
peoples but are really have been kind of
taking up and really interested in
growing nut trees this has been
something that's been happening in this
area for you know over 100 years but
there seems to be a very recent more um
invigorated interests
um and so I wanted to actually put some
numbers to this there hasn't been really
a a quantitative study of who are going
nuts in New York and how they're doing
it and why so that is what I did I
developed a survey
um and not only did I want to figure out
who we're growing nuts but also how are
they in relationship to proper extension
so these are you know extension
Educators who are in many ways
responsible for helping provide
education and services to these Growers
how well prepared our extension for this
new what seems like a new wave of of a
specialty crop in the state and also I
was really curious how do farmers who
aren't growing nuts who are growing
other things what do they think about
nut growing what just like what do
people think about nuts um
and so part of this is based in a
literature review and I did a lot of
historical work learning about the
history of not growing in New York as
well as conducting a quantitative and
qualitative
survey of both of all of commercial nut
Growers so I'm not not really in the
past it's really been focused on
hobbyists and backyard Growers and
really interested in who's interested uh
folks who are growing these as a
commercial crop
um Farmers across other kinds of sectors
in the agricultural industry and then
also Educators I'm gonna share some of
those results a little bit later but I
really want to go into
um the main things so that's um I was
just kind of giving some overview of my
previous work
uh my fourth chapter is very solidly in
agricultural field experiment that was
conducted in Varna New York where I grew
um his hybrid hazelnuts and looking at
the way that different kinds of
management variables
during Orchard establishment in years
one through three affected plant growth
pretty basic it wasn't really about
measuring yield or anything like that
but we were looking at two different
genotypes of two different ground
fertility regimes and then four
different ground cover regimes this is a
a picture from the plot
I'll show you a little bit so these were
all my treatments I had 16 different
treatment combinations
so we use ceilings and clones uh the use
of the new compost and manure or knots
and then four different kinds of ground
cover management either a cover crop uh
black plastic as like a weed mat
um unmanaged or an herbicide treatment
and so each individual plot looked like
um
within within each of one of these
children combinations
there were
four plants planted
as four replicates of the same
treatments and then each this is all 16
treatments and then each of the 16
treatments were then surrounded by a
border row
so that none of the trees were
considered On the Border they're all
inside so this is for statistical
considerations and then this was I had
four replicates of the entire uh this
entire set of
treatment combinations across the whole
field
so each treatment was was replicated
four times in a plot but then also four
times across the field and the reason
why I did this uh quadruplets uh
replication was because then in each
year I wanted to measure plant growth I
had a destructive Harvest so I'd
actually excavate each plant
um so in year one one plant would be uh
excavated then another one and then
another one and so then in the last year
there was just one tree remaining
which is why we uh that's why I designed
it this way
um and the studying area
um some weird Maps but it's right here
in in New York just a couple miles from
campus you could see the my plot from
Google Maps at least as long as those um
I'm sure next year they'll update the
maps they won't be there anymore but
um yeah that was cool to see
and we um did I did base this all on
allometric measurements so this is plan
height and stem diameter it's gonna be a
lot of nut jokes in here so just get
ready for the puns
[Music]
um
and then also the destructive harvests
um so this is just uh look showing you
some different examples of the work it
took to actually dig up these plants
especially in the last year in the early
years was very easy but then as a plant
screw really had to chase Roots because
we wanted to get that root biomass
um and so sometimes you have a plant
that just looked very innocent like this
um and then you'd find the root and
you'd realize it just kept on going
um it's kind of a little hard to see but
it just kept on going it took a lot of
work to get just one plant out of the
ground and then we just kind of shoved
all these in the back of a car to bring
them back to the Orchards where then I
cut the plants up into pieces and ground
them into powder so that I can measure
the carbon and nitrogen in their tissues
um so this this uh this is a very
important part of this design because
this is the only way to measure how much
carbon and how much biomass is in a
plant but it's also with a huge
limitation because the plants these were
only three years old and this was a
tremendous amount of work and I wasn't
able to actually
as you'll see I'll show some of the
results I wasn't able to do this for all
the plants that I wanted to so there was
some limitations in the data because of
the amount of and also you don't know
how much of the roots you're not getting
it's one of the really big issues in
doing root biomass research is there's
just there's unknown unless you grow
them in pots but of course then it's not
real soil
um and and the plants are bound in pots
so they're going to behave differently
so it's very challenging to this is just
one so if anyone's interested in solving
some research challenges we'd love to
have your ideas on how to better study
root architecture root mass
like here is a figure of some of our
main effects so each one of these
vertical bars is the different gear of
the study so one thing that's very
striking is that you really don't see
the treatment effects don't really uh
really just show themselves until year
three year three is when we really start
seeing these plants start to do
something these plants are planted as
just as seedlings or clones from year
one and you can also see the effects of
um where I wasn't able to sample
something so for instance I was only
able to dig up the roots
um so this is a root mass here in this
uh
so this is the bottom panel the bottom
horizontal panel it's all the stem mask
then this is um oh sorry this is a
little bit out of order but stems on the
bottom roots are on the top and that's
not the way it is in nature but it is
that's the way it is here and then this
is the combination root and shoot to
combined in the middle
um and so with I was only able to get
root biomass for I only chose one um for
clones
the Clone plant material
um and so that's just showing you a
little bit of limitation in the in the
data but a way that I tried to
well I'll get to that story a little bit
but um one of the main
um stories in this is if you combine
the plant material so just like average
together the values for for roots uh for
clones and ceilings like take that out
as a factor what we see is that our
ground cover managements that eliminate
weeds are the ones that results in the
most plant growth by year three it's not
a very like shocking
um result but it is very I I think that
the magnitude of difference is it's
pretty wild here and we found that a
black plastic mulch led to a
qualitatively the highest plant growth
not statistically different from
herbicide treatment so there's probably
other things that we can do to manage
weeds that are either black plastic had
some management issues and herbicide you
know if you're growing organic that's
not going to be an issue or not going to
be an option so there's probably other
kinds of weed management techniques that
could be that could be worked out
studied here
um I had high hopes for the cover crop
but I think I used the wrong mix of
seeds and I ended up doing using a cover
crop that was actually a deleterious to
to the plant growth so that's also
really important not all cover crops are
created equal and you want to make sure
that you're really choosing your cover
crop to match the kind of plant system
you're working with
but one thing I really want to try to do
because I had this issue where I was
missing data points I wanted to see if I
could use what data I did have and build
models to be able to predict values
where I wasn't able to observe them
so a lot of my work I kind of dip my toe
into modeling I didn't expect this at
the beginning but that's kind of where
research takes you sometime and so this
is uh just a relationship of observed
values between stem biomass and root
biomass and so we have a really really
great linear fit here
um
but I wasn't you know this only if I was
so if I were to I could use this to
predict root biomass from stem biomass
values pretty reliably but there wasn't
that many data points
and so I wanted to know if I could use
another measurement that I took that was
that I had more data points of to
predict
um as a proxy for stem biomass then to
then predict root biomass kind of a
two-step prediction and what I found was
that uh the date the basal diameter was
a really good predictor of of this mass
of the above ground portion of the plant
if you took the natural log of both
sides I have a lot more data points here
and was able to find a really good fit
and so basically if I took the log of
the stem of this of the stem diameter
then I could predict uh some biomass
which I could use to predict root
biomass that's kind of a two-step
process I took and so I used values that
I pre that I generated this model to
then impute them into this model
and then so I was able to build out my
my graphs uh using these predicted
values so all the um uh red are clonal
plant materials blew our seedling and
then the dot uh all the bars outlined in
dotted lines are those that I use the
models for to predict
um and so this is really there's no way
to this unfortunately there's no way to
verify this model because this is uh
using uh I'm I'm I'm showing data that I
didn't collect
um but this does show that the model it
does seem to be sensitive to the
different treatment so here on the
x-axis we have a different treatment
um
different treatments the ground cover
treatment so that was ground cover was
the most significant treatment effect
and so we do see that the model is
sensitive to the different treatments
I was able to predict that you know
black plastic would have higher mean
values than unmanaged or cover crop or
even herbicide
um so that was
um yeah that that's basically the work
that I did in this one chapter
so that kind of wraps up that one
and then the second uh chapter I'm
really going into depth here is also
really modeling heavy and this is what
uh the issue here is um
one of the not only are do these plants
chestnuts and hazelnuts provide a really
interesting food crop
um but also there are there's lots of
research and ideas about well if you
grow if you are basing agriculture
systems on trees then we are using then
trees are also taking carbon out of the
atmosphere and putting them into very
long-lived
um individuals you know chestnuts can
live hundreds or thousands of years
that's there's a hypothesis that these
kinds of systems could actually be used
to to mitigate climate change to absorb
excess carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
store them into plant biomass even soil
soil carbon pools and that we can use
these as a way of not only adapting uh
agriculture to to more environmentally
friendly methods but also really
reducing our exposure to greenhouse
gases by by sequestering this carbon and
so I want to create an equation that
could predict how much carbon is in a
chestnut tree of any age that was the
the point of this study
and
and so this
um this was based on these kinds of data
points that took trees that were ages 2
through 80. and where possible I
collected the entire plant biomass above
and below ground and that was really
only possible and in years two through
three
um and so uh years two and three were
grown in pots and also in the fields and
I was able to uproot you know measure
the entire parts of the plant
and all the other ones came from
existing plantings so I we went out to
farm fields and and and asked if they
had trees that they were going to thin
out anyway that we could
um pay them for to or or if they were
not going to already
um thin out this tree if we could pay
them to remove this tree this tree would
you know it'd be like it's lost possibly
a lost crop for them
um so I was able to guess
uh you know as much as we could we were
able to find an 80 year old tree
um and so I can show you a little bit
about so this is what
um
the Second Harvest looks like
[Music]
washing off Roots uh and the pop grown
ones and then here we actually went out
to farms and uh that was Marvin this was
at an 80 year old Chestnut planting in
Montour Falls where we cut down the the
whole tree we had strip all the leaves
off break the branches into pieces wait
weigh them measure all the leaves
um and then take samples of them and
measure them for for carbon for their
carbon content
so this is a summary table of all my
data
um
here we've got these are the allometric
measurements the diameter and height of
the different plants so you can see I
have a lot of plants that are H2 and as
the plants get older is harder and
harder to find
um you know individuals and that's the
that's another one of the limitations of
the study but it's also just it's that's
there's not many 80 year old plantings
to sample from it's also the limitations
of of of this this field of Agriculture
um and this kind of work so we really
need more long-terms if we want to
understand uh this is really a first
pass and this is uh um I'll show you
more about the equations I created but
they are the first allometric
measurements made for for Chestnut trees
in this way based off of
um based off of biomass other ones are
really based off of
just the diameter and height and um
and branching patterns
um
so we need more long-term studies so we
can verify and uh you know further make
these models more robust
um but yeah I took uh diameter Heights
we have uh carbon contents of root stems
and leaves this middle panel is just the
biomass of the plants in kilograms and
then down here we have the biomass of
the carbon content so just the carbon
content so it's this percentage
multiplied by this Mass Gives You this
that you know this is the actual grams
of kilograms of carbon in the plant
tissues so an 80 year old tree uh the
one that we've measured at least
um is you know about 600 kilograms
and just under half of that is is pure
carbon biomass carbon
another part of this is that we wanted
to capture how yield played into this
because plants you know that's part of
mass too and that's also part of the
carbon carbon goes into the plants
um and so in order to this I uh did a a
literature a literature review from all
existing literature some of it actually
unpublished across the world because
chestnuts are grown all across the world
this is also uh perhaps the first
meta-analysis of of a chestnut yields
um
so this is also all these data points
are built into the model as well for
predicting yield and there's still a lot
of variability this the chestnut
industry is still very nascent
um and we are finding which cultivars do
best wear and um and so that's why
there's a huge spread of data um and of
course two there's lots of different
locations while these are grown which is
going to affect the yields
so one of the issues I found was that
when I tried to look at how diameter
affected the mass of the stem so the
above ground biomass looking at these
very simple
um comparisons
we do not have linear relationships
right at all we have a little growth for
a long time and then it kind of shoots
up and uh if you plot the residuals you
get some really weird stuff that kind of
obliterates any of the assumptions of
linear modeling
um this is very frustrating
and so I had to do a lot of work playing
on all different kinds of
Transformations so here again is that
same relationship diameter of the stem
to the mat diameter of the stem to the
mass of the stem uh this is all
untransformed if we took the the natural
log of the mass
um it did something different it kind of
you know we saw but it's still not
really suitable for a linear regression
if we um instead the natural log of the
diameter also a different effect but not
really useful for linear regression and
of course
um the winning model is a natural blog
both of both
and so looking after this is just my
error plots and just kind of verifying
that this linear model would work well
and it um mostly does and so we kind of
just went with
um taking natural log of both axes and
going with that and so and um of course
one of the biggest issues again is being
able to measure root biomass and so one
of the first models I built for this
study was estimating group biomass based
on that log log relation linear
relationship
um so
we found also all the um all the red red
dots are observed uh root biomass and
then the blue dots are ones that the
model predicted
so we were able to maybe with very
satisfactory results able to use this
model to to predict root biomass
based on the natural log of stem
diameter which was like one of the best
um the diameter to mass was one of the
best predict the diameter was the best
predictor of mass overall Mass
and so yeah these are basically the same
curve but one is for uh biomass carbon
that's one of the other one is just for
biomass
but of course predicting the log of root
mass is not that useful we want to know
what the root mass is in its original
terms so we have this nice log log model
and now we have to back transform it
into its original units to actually be
of use
and so in order to do that you just take
the natural log I mean you raise that
relationship to to e since it's a
natural log and so that's so when we
exponentiate our model we uh we get this
really beautiful curve and these are
error terms we only have you know single
data points out here and this is at the
extreme end of our model so the errors
of course going to be very large and the
error in the log log transform space
becomes an exponent so that's also why
we see it becomes an exponent in the
linear space which is why we see these
huge error bars
um but this is this is exciting this is
a first first pass of a um
root biomass model based on diameter but
of course the question was not how do we
what
um what how much carbon does this tree
have based on its diameter it was based
on its age and that required another
kind of modeling
but after I was able to do those models
I was able to then impute
um these new values into this data set
and I was able to build out an
estimation of the whole tree biomass
um using modeled root values which is
exciting and then I could create these
really fun graphs these are sigmoid
curves that are that produce that
basically predict based on tree age now
how much growth we have
um so this is an equation for biom for a
carbon tree I mean a chestnut tree and
one of the limitations of this modeling
approach is that the model I use assumes
that the rate of change here at this at
these ends are symmetrical
and they're probably not um it's it's
probably much more likely that towards
the trees as the trees reaching maturity
uh this shoulder is really going to be
much more gradual
um than this exponential growth that's
happening when the tree is really young
but this was um this was the extent of
my my modeling abilities I'm sure there
are more we could be maybe if we got
more data points we could fit a closer
model
um
yeah and then so this is the it's the
same formula just slightly different
numbers for the carbon content
so then
um
oh yeah over 40 years so a tree seems to
um stabilize its growth kind of plateau
at about 40 years according to the study
and so
averaged over those 40 years the
chestnut tree one one single tree
tends to accumulate eight kilograms of
carbon per year
and if we put this into some perspective
about uh so a 200 250 trees per hectare
is about 100 trees per acre
and that is a common planting
um common planting density which would
create two tons of carbon per hectare
which is equivalent to 7.4 tons of
carbon dioxide equivalents per hectare
per year so that is the you know
according to this model based on actual
mass measurements that is the carbon
sequestration potential of a chestnut
planting
and to put this into some contexts uh in
New York States New York state has about
I think 7.4 million acres of land and
one million Acres of that are are
agricultural land uh you know one
million acres in total are underutilized
so to speak
um and only like 29 26 of this is
the reason I'm doing I'm talking about
marginal land is because these uh
Chestnut trees are um
they are they're still not a mainstream
crop so people are probably not going to
be like tearing out soybean fields and
and corn fields and planting wholesale
to to Chestnut trees but they the
chestnut trees do really really well on
on slope plan on land it's very acidic
and that's very Rocky
um and so marginaland is actually a
really a really great opportunity to add
to our agricultural portfolio portfolio
in ways that not only produce food but
also provide a climate benefit and so
this is the total this is the
quote-unquote marginal land in New York
and 26 of it is like readily available
for for activation for improvement so if
we took you know of this one million
Acres just 26 of it and planted that to
chestnuts
um that's equal to about 105
000 hectares or
um and at this rate we would get uh we
would be sequestering 210 tons uh 210
000 tons of carbon per year uh which is
uh equal to almost 800 000 CO2 tons of
CO2 equivalents
and to kind of put that into a grander
perspective
we as a as a globe are looking to um to
really sequester 11 gigatons so this is
a really far off this is uh
a hundredth of a percent of a gigaton
but this is really on just 26 percent of
a percent of of larger land so while it
may not make you know this in and of
itself is not going to make a dent in
the world's Global Climate problem
um it does objectively
provide a piece of this pie and you know
New York alone I mean while we need 11
gigatons agrofortion in and of itself
across the globe
um has a potential to sequester up to
5.7 gigatons of carbon dioxide
equivalent but you know on the low range
is 0.1 this is not super far off from
0.1 gigatons but um so just showing that
even within even within a small portion
of New York we can actually see that
agroforestry and planting these Woody
perennial crops really can start to help
address
um
address the call for aligning
agriculture with
um with climate smart production
and uh yeah like from
get carbon sequestration
another
um aspect of This research was looking
not so one of the um so the chestnut
trees produce these are the same sigmoid
curves that are showing plant growth
over age but one thing that wasn't
really well represented on the previous
ones was that leaves and and um and the
actual Chestnut yield the Burrs the nuts
those those get produced each year and
go away they're ephemeral as opposed to
you know the wood accumulates every year
and so you can measure how much you know
when you measure a plant's stem at age
80 that is the accumulation of the
biomass of that Single Tree over all
those 80 years but when you measure the
leaves on that 80 year old tree you're
just measuring that one year's growth so
we want to also see over the course of a
tree's life how much carbon has been
going into those ephemeral
um uh products the the nuts as well as
the leaves and so here is a cumulative
map or cumulative graph of those of
those parts
um so over an 80 year old tree's life it
produces almost a ton of carbon in
leaves alone
and this is important because this
really impacts the soil carbon
um especially the leaves the the the
um the carbon that does come from the
yield does often get exported at least
the nuts you know the the chestnuts
they're they are a nut inside of a burr
the Burr can stay in the in the land
um and and get recycled back into the
soil uh well you do have an export of
carbon and nutrients from
um you know just from selling selling
your products but the leaves can be
managed and we can actually you know
this is not just something that goes
away every week it doesn't have to be
something that goes away every year but
it actually can go and feed the soil uh
and that was you know this is a gives a
proxy or an idea to a pool of carbon
that I was not able to measure in the
study which is that which is in the soil
itself
and to kind of look at some figures from
other studies that show
um unfortunately this um
it's covering some of the information
but what we do see is that uh in a
similar uh Chestnut in a plant uh
Chestnut planting
um that's been conducted over 24 years
is that organic carbon
um is much higher in the top 10
centimeters compared to a corn soybean
rotation
and then it's about about 15 higher and
we also see another study the
agroforestry plantings
um so not just necessarily Chestnut
trees tend to uh at every soil layer
have more carbon in the soil and this is
other studies these are other
meta-analyzes just showing carbon
benefits the soil from different kinds
of agroforestry plantings
um I don't have time I don't think to go
over these in detail and then this graph
is showing
um this is a heat map these are all
different kinds of other soil
characteristics
um this is
uh just Chestnut alone this is double
planted Chestnut this is Chestnut and
Papa and this is Papa alone so we see
adding in
um plant diversity having two different
kinds of trees really increases the
number of positive
um of benefits which is another really
important important aspect of
agroforestry is not just having Woody
perennials that are not disturbing the
soil and growing your year after year
thank you Carmen um but also plant
diversity it also plays a really
important part in other kind not just
carbon but other kinds of soil benefits
that are really important
um really important and what we have
also I should say that when we have a
organic matter concentrations organic
carbon concentration is greater than two
percent it's really important because
that really uh talks about the amount uh
that really it's sort of a a factor that
affects soil so health so equality the
amount of nitrogen that's available
so more broadly across New York in uh so
this is kind of going back to the the
survey research that I did
but as you know I did all this this
quantitative work but really what is
what is the state of not growing in New
York why does this matter what is the
greater context so in 2019 alone we saw
over almost 13 000 trees uh chestnuts
and hazelnut trees being planted across
New York
um and more than like and that was great
that was seven times seven times greater
than the number of trees planted in
2017. so in those three short years
seeing a an exponential rise in a number
of farms that are planting chestnuts and
hazelnuts and the majority of these have
only started in 2016. so while nuts have
been existed in this in the state for
thousands of years and people have been
growing them for hundreds of years
there's really right now is a time of
intense really
um energetic interests in not trees and
many of these farmers are identifying
with
Organic regenerative
by Diversified kinds of plantings that
really bring together not just
production agriculture but also other
kinds of ecosystem services and more
ecological production methods
and all the ones I surveyed across the
state intend to plant more nutrients so
I've been this is not just it doesn't
seem like it's a passing fad uh it
really seems like these folks are
actually trying to build an industry and
what this looks like across the
Northeast there's actually quite a lot
of activity
um there's research institutions in the
greater eastern U.S
um there's several cooperatives
um also in like in the midwest area and
there's even one forming here the New
York shoe crop science is the a nut tree
Cooperative that's happening that's
already established right here in New
York
here is a list or just a mapping of
these are all existing Chestnut
plantings that are currently bearing in
New York I'm in the process of visiting
all these um over the next few weeks
last week I was I visited all these this
week I'll be going to the Mid Hudson and
to the Albany area meeting these Growers
taking pictures learning about the
production methods this work is being
supported by a number of different
grants the U.S USDA just injected 2.8
billion dollars into something called
climate smart Commodities of which um
nut trees are are are part of the
several awarded
um proposals in that recent
um Grant
this is a A View From the probably the
largest Chestnut Orchard in New York
state I was just out there on Friday
this is just 12 acres but about 12 000
plants
um really incredible place and the ipcc
recognized that's the inter gun rental
intergovernmental panel on climate
change recognizes the extreme importance
and demonstrated benefits of agroforshi
but notes that there is a lack of
institutional support
um in order to really ensure adequate
management but also how does this
happening on the scale needed so we
really need places like Cornell
University and other research
institutions in the Northeast to
continue doing this work if you're
interested we we need folks figuring out
how to integrate these into Diversified
cropping systems like alley cropping and
civil civil pasture
um
uh really great need for for breeding
work to be done
there's so much so much has been planted
out there and we need to figure out what
is best and how to continue supporting
these industries there's new pests and
diseases that are that are um that are
happening that we really need help with
learning how to
um do better with and anticipate new
ones
um there's really great modeling work
that can be done with uh climate
mitigation ecosystem services
and yeah if you're interested in food
science aspects
um this is some other work that's
happening around the country and thank
you so much for your time please get in
touch my contact information is here I
really appreciate your attention yes
okay any questions
yes Ken regarding theologmatory yes
which is based on uh Chinese restaurant
Melissa so mostly it's definitely for
the older ones
um the the young field-grown ones those
were European Japanese hybrids
um
but I would and then I think the sixth
year one was a Japanese Chestnut
seedling the 22 year old one came from
the Lansing planting that Ian Merwin did
that's melissima and the 80 year old was
also melissima just wondering yeah
that they're doing at Syracuse
University to kind of restore the
American chestnut I would imagine they
they might have this sort of allometric
data that you could compare to Melissa
perhaps
yeah that would be interesting those
have very different growth forms and
um I have not I haven't asked them about
that
great question yes yes thank you I was
interested in your video where you
showed it all the trees
they seem very uh
yes these are not these are all those
are seedlings they're grown on their own
Roots there's not like dwarfing
rootstocks for chestnuts grafting is a
huge issue in Chestnut um most crafts
fail
um and so that's just the nature of the
plantings that they're large
um that offers really good climate
benefits because it allows the trees to
grow to the full size so they're able to
store all that carbon but that's
currently
um that's currently the planting density
because if you plant them any denser I
mean those were not those also were not
full maturity those are all at uh about
10 12 years old you saw the plants are
not really going to finish growing until
40. so
right but there seems to be some sort of
uh in a way conflict to stop the right
word but on one hand you don't you
dealing with perhaps a yield type system
like apple trees grow over from just 60
100 years right nobody grows to that
right uh because they're focused on the
yield of the that's on the other hand
you're focus on carving sequestration
so you know
which one is more important
uh I'm just curious yeah well I think
I think the goal is not to say which one
is more important how can we beverage
the both because the idea is that
farmers might be able to get paid for
the carbon benefits that they're
bringing so we want to be able to bring
the most yield but also the most carbon
stored that could potentially be a
double source of income for these
Growers because not only they're
producing a salable crop but they're
also doing the social good
for the globe
yeah
um so I just had a question about your I
think that's the sigmoid like model yeah
um and kind of like the potential like
biological like uh impact of that so
like it's not just like just because
that's how the bottle I like to is there
a point
um you know further off x-axis in which
that stops like making sense in terms of
like tree age and then the y-axis was
like the covenants request sequestration
much levels off like at some point in
age and so is that like the biological
basis to like that like leveling off
where they choose really turn 80 and
kind of like stop putting on like you
both but not so much that they don't put
on new growth but it balances with how
much dies so there's yeah there's
there's no net there's no net New Growth
okay yeah cool
thank you very very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu